John Steele Gordon author of the
business of America what can we learn
from your book about how to get back to
normal in this country after the tragedy
in New York well I think you know this
sort of tragedy not in this scale
perhaps as has happened before I mean
the country has been attacked before and
business got back to business quite
quickly and I'm sure it will again which
one example would you give that you
think was the the best to teach you
something about what could happen well
certainly Pearl Harbor I mean the the
stock market dropped with 4.5 percent
immediately after Pearl Harbor but
within six months it was it was higher
than before and business has a great
deal to contribute to whatever effort we
we make here and I'm sure it'll is more
than willing to do so how did you
arrange this book it was arranged by
subjects in large groups of you know
about agriculture and about banking and
and government and interaction with
business and stuff like that it was we
just sort of sat there and arranged the
stories how many different stories how
many different essays I think they're 47
and when were they first published I
began writing them for American heritage
1989 is you know on page 91 you have a
chapter called the towering boondoggle
right written a long time ago yes what's
it about it's about the World Trade
Center about the building of the World
Trade Center and how it came to be and
comparing it to the Erie railway which
was built by the state of New York in
the 1830s and 40s and in the World Trade
Center was not built by private business
it was built by the Port Authority of
the state of New York in New Jersey and
it was largely at the instigation of
David Rockefeller who was that time
chairman of the Chase Manhattan Bank who
wanted to give a boost to the downtown
New York business district where the
Chase Manhattan Bank had its
headquarters which had been finished in
1960 and fortunately the David
Rockefeller his brother Nelson
Rockefeller happened to be governor of
New York and Nelson Rockefeller never
saw a large project he didn't want to
build
and so they managed to work through the
politics and get the court authority to
build what was then I guess the largest
office building in the world where'd
they get the money they borrowed at
bonds and uhm for a long while didn't
make any money no because it was an
enormous building and it was an enormous
increase in the amount of office space
for rent in downtown New York and then
the New York State government moved a
lot of offices in there but otherwise it
would have been rather embarrassingly
empty you say in your book that from an
economic standpoint the World Trade
Center has been an utter disaster
when did it start making money I think
it started making money in the in the
80s late 80s that when the when the boom
really hits in New York and then the
demand for office space went up well
then the it began to fill up how does
that compare with the Erie Canal oh well
the Erie Canal was it was a huge hit
from the very beginning the Erie Canal
was probably the most successful public
works project in the history of the
world I mean it was making money even
before it finished the Erie railway
which was a political promise made by do
it Clinton to in order to secure the
support of the what's called the
southern tier the counties along the
border of with Massachusetts lavinia and
so he promised them a highway of their
own and in the 1830s that became a
railway and the Erie railway never made
the faintest economic sense for one
thing the state of New York required to
run entirely within the state of New
York
and which made it couldn't come to New
York City because they would have to go
through New Jersey and the Erie Canal
people didn't want it coming to Buffalo
because then it might compete with the
Erie Canal so it ended up running at the
when it was finished in 1851 it was the
longest railroad in the world 451 miles
and it ran between an absolute no place
called Dunkirk New York in an absolute
in no place called Piermont New York and
there's railroad it went broke in its
entire history seven times I believe it
was a huge football on Wall Street for
years it was called a Scarlet woman of
Wall Street because it broke so many
hearts and it was just mean a great
example of why governments should for
the most part stay out of business
because they make political decisions
not financial ones where do you live now
I live in Westchester County in a town
called North Salem when did you come
down to
Washington for this program I came down
this morning but what transportation
these years I took a very crowded
Metroliner any observation about
people's attitude on this Sunday what
you saw on the train well as I thought
the train was very crowded I don't take
the Mitchell on role that often but I
assume it was it was crowded because the
shuttle isn't running and maybe a lot of
people are reluctant to take it even if
it were um but I know a lot of people
were talking about it and still full of
the newspapers and I talked with a guy
sitting next to me we talked the whole
way down about about it
what's your own feeling at this point
I'm not sure I've completely absorbed it
I mean it was just such an unbelievable
thing then I watched it on television I
was not in the city I was about to go to
the city when my friend called me up and
said turn on the television set you're
not going and so I just stepped there
all day watching it it was like some
Hollywood movie it was me with
particularly spectacular special effects
it's I still don't think I've really
quite absorbed it where is your office
in Manhattan I don't have an office in
Manhattan American heritage is at 14th
Street and Fifth Avenue and way above
the World Trade Center and are all these
essays originally from American heritage
yes
how long have you done that since 1989 I
was 12 years now and do you call
yourself a historian I call myself more
a writer than a historian because I
don't have anything beyond the BA degree
I've never been in a college I don't do
original research any what I do is I
piggyback on other people's original
research and then write stories about it
you know librarian friend of mine when
she handed me a stack of books that
obviously hadn't been read in a hundred
years she said I finally figured out
what you do you read dull books oh well
the people don't have to have the 47 in
your book which one's your favorite oh
there's a lot of ones that I like I
think it probably the one I like the
best is the about the racket club I'm
managing to manipulate the real estate
market in New York and and the rules of
the laws about what you could build and
where you could build it and ending up
turning the empty space above their
Clubhouse into five million dollars
when did that start in the 1970s when
the racket club was on Fifth Avenue's
built in the 1920 I believe and on Park
Avenue I'm sorry
and the Fisher brothers a very large
real estate firm bought land right
behind the racket club on the side
street and they wanted a Park Avenue
address because you can get much more
rent money for a Park Avenue address and
you can for a side street address which
doesn't make much sense but that's the
way the world works
and so they try to do deal with the
racket club to use their Park Avenue
address and the racket club tried to get
too much money from them and so the
Fisher brothers went to andy stein the
borough president of manhattan and andy
stein promptly gave them an address like
you know one park avenue plaza or
something like that and so the suddenly
they didn't need the the racket club
anymore and so they thought they'd
they'd won this game set and match and
then the racket club suddenly announced
that they were building a hotel over
there clubhouse which was not then
landmarked it is today and they could do
it I mean the engineering was there the
rules were there it was perfectly
possible to do it and of course it would
have ruined the Fisher brothers view
over Park Avenue they will the tenants
would have looked at a brick wall
instead of the Seagram building and st.
Bartholomew's and what-have-you and so
when all was said and done the Fisher
brothers wrote the racket club a check
for five million dollars to buy the air
rights over their club knowing what you
know if you had a lot of money or even
didn't have a lot of mine would you go
into business in New York City right now
yeah any time oh sure well if I were a
business man which I'm not I mean it
would be a very poor investment for me
to go into business anywhere but I think
New York City is a wonderful place to do
business what makes it wonderful because
it's New York I mean New York is the
last great city state it's like Venice
writ large the only thing it's not it's
not sovereign I mean that's what's
really remarkable about New York is that
it it made itself it's not as a
capitalist never been a Kappa told me
except briefly in 1790s and so while the
glories of London and
were paid for by the taxpayers of great
nation-states the glories of New York
Rome was entirely paid for by the
taxpayers of New York and even then most
of them was privately built I mean the
only really great building in New York
that was publicly built is the city hall
I mean architecture we great and they
the the city did build the New York
Public Library which is a spectacular
building but the books are owned by a
private corporation
when did Wall Street start Wall Street
started as well it was built in the
fifteen or sixteen fifties when they
built a wall to protect New York City
against invasion from New England and
then of course the British came up by
sea instead of by land so the wall
didn't do any good but it became a
financial market um starting in the in
the 1780s and became a it became a
synonym for the American financial
market in the 1830s you know came a
metonym for them for the whole apparatus
we're talking about Wall Street at after
its worst week since that depression
right knowing what has happened over the
years and your study of it in history
what's gonna happen from here on out oh
the history is after a shock like this
the market tends to take a terrible
beating and then within six months to a
year it's higher than it was before I
mean that's been the history that's what
happened after the Kennedy assassination
what happened after the Cuban Missile
Crisis what happened after Nixon's
resignation after Pearl Harbor in 1914
the when World War one suddenly broke
out to everybody's surprise Wall Street
closed for three months and it really
had no choice because every other stock
market in the world had already closed
and there was no way the New York stock
market could have function under those
conditions and a closed for three months
and then when it finally reopened fully
by
april of 1915 1915 turned out to be the
best year in the history of the Dow
Jones Industrial Average in percentage
terms is there anything unusual about
this particular situation it's different
from the others well of course what's
different this time is that Wall Street
itself was attacked I mean
we think of all the great wall street
names that were associated with the
World Trade Center Morgan Stanley Cantor
Fitzgerald dozens of others
um they were devastated quite literally
and so that's you know a lot of these
firms are now operating out of temporary
office space in New Jersey and and the
phones still are kind of shaky and stuff
again and a financial market lives on
Communications so that's that's one big
difference but I have no doubt that Wall
Street will come back made it in the
last time it was seriously bombed in
1920 it was open for business the next
day with the windows boarded up but the
stock market was functioning the morgan
bank was functioning you have a section
in there part six the business of war
right what's the point of that section
well war is a very expensive proposition
and so it always in you know there's a
there's a Chinese saying that wars are
fought with silver bullets and the
nation with the most money and the most
ability to convert its wealth into
military strength is the country that
ends up winning the war almost always oh
so yeah well there have been lots of
times when the effects of warming the
the Civil War transformed the financial
system of the United States for instance
I mean the IRS was born in the Civil War
by no means the least of the effects of
that war and the modern paper money
system was born in the in the Civil War
for instance World War two what much of
the technology that transformed the
world after world war ii came about
because of world war ii in radar our
large airframes
but without which the modern airplane
industry couldn't exist or the airline
industry couldn't exist and the computer
of course was originally meant to UM in
order to calculate artillery
trajectories I'm gonna turned out to be
good for all kinds of things the first
essay is a USS pork barrel right no this
was the USS Pennsylvania
and it started out as a good idea but
you know government projects often take
on a life of their own because they they
build up constituents around them who
are who are benefited by and what
happened was in the war of 1812 while we
had some wonderful single ship successes
against the British Navy the the Royal
Navy was so much larger than the US Navy
that eventually we were bottled up and
and our Commerce was on a standstill and
what-have-you and Congress wanted to
build they have a Navy so that we could
if not defeat the Royal Navy in a future
war at least we could hold our own and
greatly complicate their strategic
planning and so they ordered six ships
of the line and all they did was order
that it be not less than 74 guns and so
the Navy saw this opening and warded up
a Leviathan called the USS Pennsylvania
which had a hundred and thirty six guns
it was by some measures the largest
wooden warship ever constructed and it
took 17 years to build in the
Philadelphia Navy Yard most of the time
the construction only took place around
elections for a few months before each
election though suddenly there be
carpenters all over the USS Pennsylvania
and finally it was finished and it
sailed down to the Norfolk Naval Base
down southern Virginia from Philadelphia
and never set sail again I mean it was
obsolete the minute it was finished and
it was finally burned at the when the
Navy evacuated the Norfolk Navy base in
the beginning of the Civil War the
Pennsylvania was burned over to the
waterline and never was never rebuilt by
the Confederates anybody else where did
they phrase pork-barrel come from well
we're not entirely sure it showed up in
the in the Roosevelt era in the first
Teddy Roosevelt era and it probably had
to do with the fact that pork barrels we
mean slaves in the South used to be fed
they would be handed out joints of pork
from the barrel and this was so handing
out goodies to to everybody and so it's
probably a democratic coinage because
the South was solidly Democratic and of
course the Democrats were out of office
during the early part of the 20th
century and so mean
one man's pork barrel of course is
another man's vital national project
depends on whose constituents are
benefited by it
you also mentioned in that essay that
thirty years later the the word
boondoggle came into being yes well that
apparently was coined by now out of
office Republicans who use it means
basically the same thing it's a
government project designed to win votes
not for any real economic utility Jake
cook invented the bond drive invented
the bond drive and before you explain
that from what you know of bond drives
you think we're gonna need one I don't
know it depends on what kind of war this
turns out to be mean it's going to be I
mean if it turns into what I'd be very
surprised if it turned into what we
recognize as a war in a conventional
sense of armies clashing on open ground
so if it if it turns into a major war
yes indeed we will be having bond drives
again who was Jake cookin when did when
did he invent the bond Ray J cook was a
Philadelphia banker born in Sandusky
Ohio and in the beginning of the Civil
War being the United States was spending
about I think it was one hundred and
forty thousand dollars a day was the the
daily expenses of the federal government
in 1860 they were spending a million
dollars a day by the time Bull Run came
in the in the summer of 1861 and the
money was just where are we gonna get
the money they salmon chased the
Secretary of the Treasury
went up to Wall Street managed to borrow
fifty million dollars which at the time
was a very very large underwriting for
Wall Street and Davis needed to find a
way to raise incredible amounts of money
the the federal debt in 1860 was 65
million dollars by the end of the Civil
War was 2.4 billion dollars and Jay
Cooke found a way to do this by selling
bonds at you could buy them as small as
$50 and he
so Linda everybody I mean before the
Civil War far fewer than 1% of the
American population had owned any kind
of securities at all by the end of the
war Jay Cooke had sold bonds to about 5%
of the of the population which was
really a remarkable achievement and ever
since meaning everybody ever the country
in the world said boy is this a good
idea what about World War 2 you have any
idea how much money was raised through
the bond ranch I don't have the figures
I know it was a colossal amount I mean
most wars are usually financed on
borrowed money not on taxes because you
you can't raise enough through taxes to
to fight a war your essay the
armor-plated scandal oh the armor plate
scandal was took place in the late 19th
century when the government was
beginning to rebuild the Navy and we
beginning of the 20th century we had the
second largest Navy in the world after
the Royal Navy but we needed armor plate
and armor plate is very tricky stuff to
manufacture and steel companies never
liked manufacturing it much to begin
with because um by its nature it is what
we called a monopsony there's only one
buyer in the market and that's the
United States Navy so if you didn't sell
your armor plate to them you didn't sell
it to anybody and so can-do Carnegie and
other steel manufacturers weren't too
keen about doing it but they got talked
into it for patriotic reasons and then
the various political reasons they
essentially got shafted they mean a lot
of politicians made hay out of a phony
scandal and about blow holes which are
abnormal part of good armor plate but
the Navy had written all these
specifications mean bureaucrats who knew
nothing whatever about the manufacture
of steel wrote all these specifications
and the head of the homestead works to
the part of Carnegie steel Empire named
Charlie Schwab he just went ahead and
made the armor plate and he was very
much given to you know doing the job now
and you know worrying about the details
later
and there was a lot of labor unrest at
that time and then the unions in effect
turned them in and then they have this
kangaroo
I mean they didn't they didn't bother to
call Carnegie they just held hearings
based on the evidence presented by the
by the labor unions and then found them
guilty this was not exactly justice but
they paid the fine anyway and then they
in World War one they the government
tried to build an armored plate factory
of its own and it came in over a
thousand percent over budget and it took
that wasn't finished till the war was
over and did one run of armor plate
costing three times as much as the steel
companies are perfectly willing to sell
it for and a close never worked again I
mean it was a complete total loss of
money we have a last paragraph want to
read in this essay you say for the last
100 years leftist politics or ian's have
been regularly dredging up the armored
plate scandal as an example of
capitalist greed at its worst what it
really is of course is one more example
of government incompetence both as a
customer and as a manufacturer who are
leftist historians over there quite a
few of visit any almost any college
campus in the country and Ian you can
have lunch with half a dozen of them and
it goes back to the turn of the century
I mean Ida Tarbell the muckrakers Gustav
forget his last name I'm afraid who
wrote a three-volume economic history of
the United States and and he knew just
where to place the blame in the same
place Ralph Nader places the blame for
absolutely everything the corporations
and this is tendentious history at its
worst often mean Ida Tarbell she was a
great propagandist but not a good a star
him most history in the United States
written by certain political point of
view is more so now than it used to be I
believe it's been the fate of capitalism
that mean
the very word capitalism was coined by
Karl Marx and the history of capitalism
has been to a very large extent written
by at enemies historians who
look down at business I mean they
regarded as the best a grubby affair
unlike their own high-flown profession
and so I you know they're out to prove a
point many of them I mean there are many
great academic historians and there I
mean people like them Alfred Chandler of
Harvard it was a great business istari
and it was certainly not guilty of this
but there are others who are they have
an agenda and they're gonna push it how
would you describe your own background
politics well of the ology well I've
tried to stay away from ideology I think
ideologies are used by people as a
substitute for thought I'm I believe in
free markets in to the extent that they
are possible I mean there are times when
you cannot have a free market I mean the
18th century they had you know the cure
the way they handled famine was the rich
aid and the poor starved
that is not acceptable in the modern era
but we haven't had a famine lately
either and free markets need to be
regulated they're not self-sustaining
they will self-destruct if there aren't
regulators could I forget who it was who
said that the trouble with socialism is
socialism but the trouble with
capitalism is capitalists and they will
always see their short-term advantage in
the market rather than for themselves
rather than seek to sustain the market
as a whole for sustaining the market as
a whole is the function of society as a
whole because of society as a whole is a
benefit for from it and therefore I mean
you need referees in the market just the
same way as you need the referees at the
Superbowl because well there's a lot at
stake people are willing to cheat I
brought a Washington Post article from
this morning's newspaper with me to ask
you about it the headline on it is line
of US bailout supplicants grows some
lawmakers expect express reluctance to
extend federal assistance further this
is all off of the 15 billion dollars
voted for the airlines and to start with
what's your reaction to that
15 billion well I think in this
particular instance because of what has
happened I don't
Airlines either they get assistance from
the federal government or a lot of them
are simply going to go out of business I
mean this is going to be a bloodbath I
would hope that it was structured in
such a way as the government can recoup
in times of prosperity airline business
is a very peculiar business just like
the railroad business in the 19th
century was it's extremely capital
intensive and the expenses tend to go on
whether the airplanes are full or empty
and it you know it costs just as much to
send an empty airplane across the
country as it does to send a full one
and so once you get above a certain
passenger load every passenger after
that is pure gravy it doesn't cost any
more money but any passenger below that
break-even point is pure loss and so
it's a feast and famine business and
then good times they tend to make a lot
of money but in four times they tend to
hemorrhage money and I'm not sure that
there's a solution to that in this case
it's because it's the impact was so
enormous that I think you know the there
has to be some sort of help now on once
you help out one group you always find a
line stretching from Washington of the
Mississippi River saying me too
I mean J look out I was injured in the
you know gardening business or whatever
I mean this happened in 1929 when
Herbert Hoover promised the farmers
relief tariff relief by raising tariffs
on agricultural products in order to
protect the American market for American
farmers who were having a terrible time
in 1929 and when they got through they
had a absolute feeding frenzy and in
Washington and what the result was the
smoot-hawley tariff which was one of the
primary causes for the Great Depression
would turned a ordinary recession into
the great economic calamity of American
history how did that work well what
happened was they would the highest
tariffs in American history on the
smoot-hawley tariff and what it did was
just fully destroyed world trade I mean
all over the world because other
countries had no choice but to raise
tariff walls of their own they couldn't
you know they couldn't sell their goods
to America they weren't about to let
Americans sell their goods to
Switzerland or
or wherever and so everybody's terrace
walls went up to meet our tariff walls
and world trade simply collapsed and in
the United States we were doing about
five billion dollars a year in world
trade in 1929 by 1934 we're doing about
1 billion left to get the exact figures
but it was something like that
and it wasn't till World War two that
trade were covered in this article by
Juliet Eilperin in the Washington Post
there's some further comments about
other industries wanting money it says
other industries closely tied to the
aviation they've also appealed to the
Congress for help in recent days
suggesting that they have suffered such
severe losses they need direct federal
assistance
Richard M Copeland president of the
American Society of travel agents has
asked for 4 billion in federal grants
and no interest loans to cushion the
blow of the recent airline shutdown he
emphasized that airlines have cut travel
agents commissions by more than a half
over the past 7 years
where does this start stop or where
should it stop well I don't know I I
mean I I can't speak specifically to the
travel agency business because I don't
know that much about it I know that they
have been they've been having a bad time
for long before this happened because
the internet is in a sense eliminating
middlemen and travel agents or middleman
in the old sudden you don't need the
travel agent anymore you can go on the
internet and make your own reservations
and find out all you need to know and so
travel agents are having a very bad time
and I think you know we can't help out
everybody because you know then we turn
into a socialist country and that's
guaranteed to be a failure but you say
you're believe in free markets why
wouldn't you just let these Airlines let
it let it the market decide in this
process well cuz I think in this case
the blow was so extraordinary and so
sudden that there's no time to adjust
and I think you do be a an awful lot of
damage would be done that would take
years to recover from I mean I think you
know well I certainly don't want the
government simply to write them a check
saying ok you guys have had a bad time
here's a billion dollars I mean there's
got to be some way they have to pay it
back in you know like the Chrysler
bailout which in that particular case I
don't think I would have
been in favor of but Chrysler did pay
back the money when good times returned
so you expect these airlines to have to
pay this money back I would hope so
I mean I don't know what the legislation
is I haven't read the legislation but I
would hope who'd be structured in some
such way that the government gets it
back based on all the wars that you've
covered in their history essays what
kind of financial condition is this
country and today looking ahead to what
could be as they said as the government
says a long drawn-out war oh we're in
very good shape we're much better shape
now than we were 10 years ago I mean 10
years ago the government was running
deeply deeply in the red and now we're
we're in surplus I mean even this year
which has not been a banner year for the
American economy where the the surplus
is gonna be about a hundred and fifty
billion dollars which is that's a lot of
money and we've paid down a lot of the
debt that we had borrowed before for
very bad reasons in the 70s and 80s and
so that money is now available to borrow
again if we need it I mean that's you
know you can't borrow a dollar twice and
we've paid back a lot of it so now it's
it's there too if we need to dip into
the tilt has there ever been a war
that's been bad for this country
economically the Vietnam War was because
I think Lyndon Johnson tried to give us
both guns and butter both the Great
Society and the Vietnam War and it led
to it and the worst inflation we've had
since the Civil War and so I mean the
Vietnam War gave us the the economic
malaise of the of the seven days high
inflation high unemployment which is
under Keynesian terms supposed to be
impossible you're a last essay in the
section on war is the American super
weapon what was that that was a man
named Donald Nelson who had worked for
Sears Roebuck and he became head of the
war production board after Pearl Harbor
and in which the United States turned
itself temporarily into a command
economy and it was an astonishing
performance in the the civilian economy
at the end of the Second World War was
about the same size that had been at
beginning of the of the Second World War
and we'd added on top of that a war
economy of virtually the same size the
American economy doubled in the war
years and almost all of that was war
production and Donald Nelson was the man
who organized this and and commanded it
I mean he was you know he would get what
the armed services needed he'd find out
where the the stuff could be
manufactured he'd find out where the
industrial materials needed were and
he'd assign priorities to them means
some things that were in very short
supply and it'll be rubber because most
of the rubber had come from Malaya which
was in Japanese hands and so we started
a synthetic rubber industry virtually
from scratch by the end of the war we
were producing with a than a thousand
tons a year but the military is
absorbing all of that same so World War
two of those who lived through it
remember it as the Golden Age of flat
tires because you simply couldn't get
new tires unless you were at least
before store general later on you in a
chapter on engine Charlie Wilson you say
that in 1954 the Defense Department ran
by far the most powerful military
operational world but that power came at
a fearful cost to the American taxpayer
the Pentagon consumes sixty percent of
the federal budget and one dollar out of
every eighth of GNP why was it so high
in 1954 well because we're fighting a
cold war which was mean by the grace of
God it didn't get hot but it would have
been even more expensive but 60% of the
federal budget was because remember that
time the federal budget did not have I
mean didn't have Medicare Medicaid and
other social costs like that I mean the
military budget is still very large but
it's a much smaller percentage of the
the federal budget it's also now a much
smaller percentage of GNP it's now I
think um about 5% something like that
who was engine Charlie Wilson engine
Charlie Wilson was the president of
General Motors he was called engine
Charlie Wilson because one of the great
coincidences in American history that
when the the president of General Motors
was Charles
Wilson and the president of General
Electric who was Charles E Wilson they
were not related to each other and so
one was called Engine Charlie and the
other was electric Charlie and engine
Charlie had started out as he actually
came from a fairly socialist background
his father claimed to work for Eugene be
Debs and what-have-you and he was at a
union card Charlie Wilson of the Union
car which he had on his desk he was very
proud of and he he was the one who first
thought up the idea of guaranteed wages
for industrial workers I mean so if they
were laid off they would still get a
percentage of their of their wages to
see them through the bad times and he
more or less arranged for the United
Auto Workers to demand this and then
gave it to him and he also was
instrumental in developing pension funds
for industrial workers and Peter Drucker
the great business guru said to him well
you know that the American workers will
end up owning the stock and the
corporations in a few generations of you
if you have this and Charlie Wilson said
that's just the way it should be I mean
Charlie Wilson was a great hero and then
unfortunately for him he went to
Washington and found out just how nasty
a town this can be because he was asked
in a closed session when the first
confirmation hearing as Secretary of
Defense he was asked if he if it was
necessary could he make a decision that
was good for the United States but
adverse to the interests of General
Motors and he said he certainly could
make such a decision but he couldn't
imagine such a situation coming about
because what was good for the United
States was good for General Motors and
vice versa and a lot of people leaked
this and changed turn the vice versa
into what is good for General Motors is
good for the United States signed
Charles E Wilson I mean it was the most
egregious intellectual dishonesty you
can possibly imagine but welcome to
Washington where's your home originally
New York City I was born on 17th Street
and 2nd Avenue what were your parents
like you know are they still alive and
what did they do
no they were there long since dead my
father was
a writer at one point a television
producer he then went into running um
rental car franchises in the French West
Indies and my mother was oscar
hammerstein secretary did you know him
indeed but my mother's second husband
was his brother so he was uncle hawk how
did you get into the writing business
like more or less fell into it and I use
I've always loved books um ever since I
was old enough to read I had my nose in
a book and I went to work for a
publisher after I graduated from college
Harper Harper & row it was then Harper
Collins now and then I went I traveled
for a while then I went to work for her
Linda do congressman as his New York
press secretary which was a wonderful
job cuz I had absolutely nothing to do
because the press releases were all
written in Washington all I had to do
occasionally was you know send them
around and so I started going over the
public library and doing research and
writing stories and I would wrote a
story on the gold panic about 1869
probably the most exciting single day in
the history of Wall Street and I want to
see what had been done on the Erie Wars
which was about the Erie Wars of the the
fight for control of the Erie railway
between Commodore Vanderbilt and Jay
Gould and Jim Fisk and Daniel drew and I
was astonished to discover that nobody
written a book about it since the 1870s
and was written by the Adams brothers
Charles Francis Adams and Henry Adams
called chapters of Erie and so I decided
to write a book on the Erie Wars which
came out in 1988 called The Scarlet
woman of Wall Street American heritage
to call me up and ask me to write their
business history column and I said thank
you very much I'd be delighted and so
I've been in this business ever since
who owns American heritage gets owned by
Forbes did they ask you to be a free
marketer if you write for American
heritage no they've never asked me to do
anything million like that I mean yeah I
imagine if I started turning out essays
you know demanding the means of
production be owned by the people or
something I'm not sure how long I'd be
working for Forbes but no they've never
even suggested that I will
like how long have you done I mean that
not how long but how often do you do a
column for American heritage in every
issue and there are eight issues a year
under your chapter King Cotton you start
off by saying as any faithful reader of
the old gossip columns knows great
wealth - easily acquired can be a very
mixed blessing indeed why well because a
lot of people who woke up one morning
and found themselves rich beyond the
wildest dreams of avarice didn't leave
very fulfilling lives I mean they they
end up you know running racehorses and
sleeping till noon and going out to
fancy restaurants every night and they
never do anything and you know no coward
who knew what he was talking about
because he did both with great
enthusiasm once said that work is so
much more fun than fun and a lot of
people who were inherit vast wealth at
an early age um never find that out they
never worked and all they have is fun
and the fun doesn't turn out to be much
fun after a while supposedly at the
heart of the hatred for this country
from some of the Osama bin Laden
followers is because of our wealth and
because of our lifestyle I'm not sure
that's true
I'm not sure how much they know about
our lifestyle um I met Franklin
Roosevelt once the way to convince the
Soviet Union the superiority of the
United States would be to bomb them with
Sears Roebuck catalogs I'm just not sure
that they've really know much about
American life and I mean Osama bin Laden
himself has come from an extremely
wealthy family and so I mean yeah well
Will Rogers once said that I've been
rich and I've been poor and believe me
rich is better I think most of those
people I think they resent their own
poverty they don't resent American
wealth and they've often been
manipulated as to deflect from their own
governments deflect their anger onto the
United States as if we are somehow
responsible for their poverty which
we're not then for the most part their
own governments are responsible for
their poverty
another thing they seemed not to like is
women out front in any way or visible
and they want them covered and it's just
an aside and has nothing to do with them
at all but I noticed in your book almost
every there's not a woman featured in
the book that I can remember is that in
business is that does that strike you as
I mean kids are way to explain that well
the easiest way to explain it is these
are stories of business history and
women's contributions to business
relatively recent mean yeah yeah I
didn't I didn't mean - it wasn't
accusing you not having women in your
book is like why not why in history have
men almost no women played much role in
the in the history of business well for
a long while just it was it was thought
that was not a woman's place and that
you know the traditional division of
labor was that women would run the home
and men would go out and earn the
livelihood and that's that's the way it
wasn't and so women didn't have a chance
to get into business and they in the
rare occasions when they did get into
business they were either resented or
made fun of I mean Eddie green was made
one of the great American fortunes she's
the only woman to made her own fortune
although she started out rich but she
greatly multiplied that fortune um you
know the top 40 richest Americans who
ever lived and Eddie green is the only
woman and um she was a figure of fun now
she was she was a genuine miser which is
a very rare psychological phenomena I
mean there's a lot of people who are
keeps gates but she was obsessed with
not having enough money I mean she was
she had the same attitude towards money
as anorexic have towards fat they always
perceived themselves as being fat
regardless of the fact you know they're
clearly not and had to green always
perceived herself to be poor although
she was one of the half dozen richest
people in the country and she led a very
sad life in many ways what's your sense
if you were to do another book like this
in 50 years would women be in it Oh
indeed they would
I mean in the last 50 years of which I
don't have a great many stories I mean
they're the mots of of women who have
achieved great things in business and
there'll be many more because you know
they they they haven't been in the
pipeline I mean so they couldn't be a
CEO of a major corporation because they
didn't start out soon enough but no I'm
sure women will be I mean they're every
bit as capable of making a buck as men
off and for the most part much more
capable of keeping it you tell us that
your great-great great-grandfather
exchanged 35 acres of land for what a
horse and horse and a saddle saddle and
that that land turned out to be part of
Nashville yes it's downtown Nashville
that's where Capitol Hill is and then in
just the heart of Nashville how much of
your history goes to Nashville Tennessee
the Gordon's come from Tennessee I mean
my grandfather came up from Tennessee in
1898 when he was 16 any relation to the
congressman Bart Gordon when I was there
no and in your book you feature
different individuals in history then I
want you to guy just want to go through
a few of them and get you to talk about
them Isaac singer I'm sorry Isaac singer
oh they ride the sewing-machine he was
yeah he was he was a fascinating man who
were born tinkerer he wanted to be an
actor he was a mediocre actor but he was
a great tinkerer and he invented the
sewing machine he
Eliza Howe had made a sewing machine and
got a patent on it but the trouble with
how sewing machine was it didn't work
and singer made the sewing machine that
worked and so eventually they in the
first patent pool they you know divided
the spoils and then singer became
extremely rich he was a an odd man in
some ways I mean he was married a couple
of times had endless numbers of mistress
had 20 or 24 illegitimate children and
when he died he left them all about
$200,000 H and of course the
newspapers had a field day with all of
these children suddenly appearing like
mushrooms and he was um I don't think it
was a very nice man but he he did a
great service for the women of the 19th
century the sewing machine
we not only greatly know what the price
of clothes but it greatly improve of the
living standards of women he starts you
book off with a quote from Peter Cooper
I have always recognized that the object
of business is to make money in an
honourable manner I have endeavored to
remember that object of life is to do
good i Cooper of Cooper Union of Cooper
Union explain all that how did that
happen Peter Cooper started off as a
poor boy his father wasn't very
successful he only had a year or so of
formal education and yours bitterly or
not bit early but he regretted the lack
of education and when he became rich
which he did very soon um he was a born
businessman he bought a glue factory for
two thousand dollars in the first year
made ten thousand dollar profit and was
soon earning a hundred thousand dollars
a year from his glue factory and went
into steel he built the first locomotive
in the United States he owned wire
factories um he was a major player in
the laying of the Atlantic cable and the
organizing the telegraph system of the
United States and in the 1850s he
founded the Cooper Union he also he
invented night school because he had he
thought you know people like him
starting off who had to work for a
living but they could study at night and
at that time there was there was no way
to do that and so he made the Cooper
Union so that they were night classes
and he really invented the concept of
night school and he organized the Cooper
Union which is an engineering school and
had a free library anybody could use it
not just students and the Cooper Union
to this day does not charge tuition oh
it's I believe it's the only private
university in the in the United States
that does not although some of them have
plenty of money um they still charge
plenty of tuition was he around when
Abraham Lincoln made his famous speech
indeed yeah he didn't cooperate on
around 1880 Evelyn
and I'm I don't know if he was in the
audience I would be surprised if he was
not when he made his famous house
divided speech at the Cooper Union
Sylvester Graham Elsa Vesta Graham was
the first of the great health nuts in
the United States he was a clergyman he
was very sickly like great many health
nuts they he didn't live very long there
may be some connection there I don't
know but he had no background in science
whatsoever and but it was had a great
gift for gab he was a good preacher
and he started preaching about Graham
diet and I forget exactly what the
details of the diet were but it was you
know as somebody once said about about
health nuts is if if you like it don't
eat it I mean they never tell you to eat
steak and french fries it's you know
always these twigs and sawdust pudding
as Ralph Waldo Emerson described it and
Sylvester Graham ascribed the spread of
cholera to excessive lewdness and
chicken pie and he was you know his time
passed and he was forgotten but he
thought he was he would be a yeah the
people would make a pilgrimage to his
house and in fact his house turned into
a tavern um but he is famous for one
thing does he invented the graham
cracker the interstate highway system
how'd that happen it happened because of
an army captain after World War one
thought it would be fun to join an army
expedition which was to cross the
country by powered vehicles by trucks
and they didn't have jeeps then but um
the equivalent and they started off from
Washington there's a apparently a
monument outside of the White House
somewhere I figured exactly where on
them on the mall that this was where
this expedition started and and they
made their way slowly across the country
and it took them two months and they
often the roads were just non-existent
for the to a large extent and very slow
and they they had to remake the bridges
because they were too narrow to get
trucks Oh
and they finally got there and the army
put out a big report about how the need
for a proper highway systems for
national defense purposes and of course
like most army reports that got put in
at the nearest file drawer and
completely forgotten but then the that
army captain who thought would be fun to
spend the summer on this expedition in
the 1950s he became president the United
States and he was able to push it
through and it was of course Dwight
Eisenhower the Cadillac Cadillac was a
luxury car I mean it was started as a
luxury car with always a luxury car and
it nearly died in the depression because
it was never really made money and the
man who was he was in charge of the
maintenance of catalog of Cadillac and
he would beef wondered why it was that
so many of the customers at Cadillac
dealers were black
whereas Cadillac had a policy of not
selling to Black's as they wanted their
cars to be prestige and so they didn't
want to have black customers and yet all
half the customers for the maintenance
were black and so he found out what it
was of course it was you know Cadillac
dealer wouldn't sell the car directly to
a black man the black man would go out
to find some white man who would buy it
and you know give him $200 and take the
car and it was cars and we'll have a few
prestige items that successful blacks in
the 20s and 30s could indulge in I mean
they couldn't go to fancy nightclubs
they couldn't live in fancy apartment
buildings um but they could drive a
fancy car and so this man whose name I'm
sorry I just kept I cannot think of well
his name is at the moment he was the
German and he he said let's try to sell
the car to to these customers who are
anxious for and then they did and then
he made Cadillac profitable within a
year and then he revolutionized the
manufacture of Cadillacs he said that
just because their prestige car doesn't
mean they can't be manufactured
according to mass production methods
that's like Chevrolet is just using
better parts and and more careful
design and what-have-you and so within a
couple of years Cadillac having the
money-loser for General Motors was
General Motors most successful car and
then they became head of Chevrolet after
the war and unfortunately he became down
with um with throat cancer and died when
he was only about 46 otherwise he quite
possibly would have um replaced Charlie
Wilson as president of General Motors
how often in your look at history are
you surprised by things like you know
these essays like the graham crackers
thing about to so I'm always surprised
um I mean that's one of the things I
love about this job is that yeah you get
to find out about these things and you
always find the most amazing
coincidences and things you didn't know
and you know it's I love to learn and
this is a great way to learn where did
you go to school I went to st. Bernard's
and in New York and I went to Mill Brook
School um up in Dutchess County a
boarding school and then I went to
Vanderbilt University in Nashville
Tennessee what'd you study history you
uh you have of chapters says our IP rest
in peace ICC and that's the
understanding Commerce Commission you
say self enforcing laws are in
everyone's interest except for one group
the people who make and enforce the laws
to start with those who work for
government legislators and bureaucrats
alike prefer to manage problems rather
than solve them exactly because I mean
if a bureaucracy solved the problem they
were there to handle well then they'd be
out of a job means they're not about to
solve it if they can possibly avoid
doing so and yeah self enforcing law is
a law that simply takes care of itself
in the example I used was in the Roman
army they used to make very large loaves
of bread and the loaves were enough for
two soldiers for a day and so the Roman
army had a rule that one soldier would
cut the loaf in half and the other
soldier would choose which half he
preferred to have and so there was no
cheating no fights you know because the
same was true of the legions as it was
you know true in every army is it hurry
up and wait and so the soldiers had a
bad
getting into fights and they couldn't
fight over food because of this rule and
the ICC came into existence because the
railroads were gouging to a
fare-thee-well what happened was the
railroads on the trunk lines between
like Chicago and New York I mean they
competed fiercely on those trunk lines
because you know if you could ship from
Chicago to New York on the New York
Central on the Erie railway on the
Pennsylvania and so they had to compete
for the business but on the branch lines
off of these trunk lines each railroad
had a monopoly I mean so if if you were
a manufacturer in Chicago and want to
ship to New York well you could choose
your railroad if you were manufacturing
Altoona and while to ship to New York
while you shipped on the Pennsylvania oh
you didn't ship and so the the railroads
would really stick it to these customers
where they had a monopoly and the
customers not surprisingly presented it
and so they went to government this is
one of the causes of the rise of
liberalism or of the left was the
overweening power of a corporations at
the end of the 19th century and this in
the railroads were the the textbook
example of this and so what finally
happened was the Interstate Commerce
Commission which was eventually enabled
to set prices and to control the
industry and actually before came into
existence the Pennsylvania Railroad said
we'd like nothing better than a
government agency that allowed us to
make a guaranteed profit a cartel in the
sense and that's exactly what the ICC
promptly turned into because they the
ICC had to be headed by people who
understood the railroad business well
they had to come from the railroads and
they thought like railroad men and they
promptly conspired under the ICC to make
a cartel and so the railroads became as
always happens in cartels they became
fat dumb and lazy an innovative and the
railroad slowly declined and then
finally in the 1970s the prices were
finally deregulated and the ICC had
nothing to do although still stuck
around for 20 years then it was
deregulated in the
like 77 and went out of business and in
1995 I mean for 18 years I have no idea
what they did and they pushed stacks of
paper from one side of the desk to
another we'll go back to your philosophy
that legislators and bureaucrats alike
prefer to manage problems rather than
solve them how does that bode for us
then in the next you know this crisis
we're in right now well no this is the
kind of problem that governments are
paid to manage and I mean how it'll turn
out for business I don't know I mean the
the trend now for the last 30 or 40
years has been deregulatory you know to
let the free market work where the free
market can work in allocating resources
and setting prices because free markets
are so much more efficient than the best
bureaucracy in the world at doing
exactly that I mean the Soviet Union
tried to run their economy by a
bureaucratic method and of course it was
an utter disaster it simply couldn't
produce the goods and services our guest
has been John Steele Gordon and this is
what the book looks like it's called the
business of America thank you very much
thank you